Teresa made plans to reach out to
opposition parties after she suffered
that now-infamous largest Commons defeat
in British political history on her
brexit deal regardless of success
reaching across the aisle is a good way
to start uniting our bitterly divided
country remain errs like me doggedly
reject the idea that we can get a deal
with the EU that we better than the one
we already have as members and we warned
against No Deal chaos levers on the
other hand argued tough we won and that
we should have some faith in boisterous
Britain's ability to bounce back after
Brick City as soon as it got free from
its bottom the brexit genie has divided
spouses families close friends and
political parties we have all
occasionally been guilty of being unable
to empathize with opposing perspectives
and giving in to lazy tribal identities
rather than doing the emotional heavy
lifting needed to pull through this
country through the crisis delaying
article 50 our peoples vote no deal or a
renegotiated deal
whatever happens next let it be a
decision that is made collectively by
Parliament or even national unity
government this division has to stop you
don't agree never has there been an
issue that has divided this country so
much in it young against old young in
the old
it's a classic I think politics is a
result of this will become more
class-based and bitter because we have
the working classes against the
so-called liberal elite and the
intelligentsia and nevermind Scotland
and England 62 percent of which has got
a virtual event and there has been rage
and shock and disgust but I think I
think in one thing and all the polls
show this that society is fundamentally
agreed and that is Mainers and levers
are like want to just get on with brexit
they want to do it every poll says they
want to just get on and finish it I
don't think we're gonna have a problem
trading with Brussels after this is all
about they're not least because the
matter which way to go not least because
Germany's about to go into recession
Italy already is Frances and cares I
think they're gonna need our trade and
our business more than ever I'm not
worried about what happens to us but but
I just think the biggest divide now is
between politicians and the people that
they represent
and I think this is gonna be huge pop
and I think whatever happens next and
whatever when it wherever we go I think
all that all the rebels the people who
have who have led this rebellion in
Parliament and the people say against
them I think they have to be got rid of
and I think there will be any where that
constituents that they're part they're
there the consistency parties are
already threatening it because they
cannot operate in a post brexit
government when they don't agree with
the concept of it so I think one of the
ways we can heal the wounds is to get
rid of you know whatever happens
wherever we're going and if we do leave
the European you can't have people who
are fundamentally opposed to it after
breakfast after breaks it sounds a bit
to me like a purge I would argue suggest
maybe maybe it is a purge but how can
you have someone who is so opposed to
bread is it like a Dom Laguna
implementing actually it's gonna make us
say how because the mandate the Nelson
Mandela model of reconciliation it after
times of national crisis I know but what
I'm saying is a better way I think you
know for example I suggested a national
unity government if we do brexit if we
do a better way would be for the hard
break centers who would then be in power
you know that whoever becomes Prime
Minister to bring those others back into
the tent and work with them I think that
could help heal the country what Majid
is trying to find is what tone should be
an actually a national unity government
is not a bad idea to cower you you want
to resolve it by purging everybody I
think you have to get rid of people who
were fundamentally just a language get
rid we've got to include everybody I
would argue you would not think that
them out I think do you not think that
the attitude in Parliament now is
totally uncompromising I don't sighs yes
I can't see it easily breaks it but if
you go to country after country you'd be
going to the America you've got exactly
the same as an interesting quote from a
guy called Professor timbale at Queen
Mary University who says for Britain
political stability is a quaint
relic voters are becoming more volatile
over time more consumerist much more
willing to switch depending on the offer
voters are no longer so easy to please
and we shouldn't see this as an AB
this is the new normal and I think I
don't think that's probably right and
you'll sin that's why it's we're doing
it ever breaks it but you're seeing it
right in all sorts of European countries
us and in America over Trump
I mean chompy's is a result of this not
a know whose weekend will be the tense
weekend of little Asia and they'll be
out I think what's going on and I found
it fascinating because the dirt believe
this is just a brexit thing I think
brexit is highlighting it I think
there's a sentiment and it's gone on for
a very long time that people's view is
if you have a certain viewpoint that
view is discarded and is censored
because it's not seen to be politically
correct and I think that this is where a
lot of this stuff stems from bricks it
is a symptom of it but I think that it
started way beyond that and like you
mentioned the yellow vests and stuff in
France there will be people that say
that that is that that protest ongoing a
significant protest is not accurately
represented amongst the media in the way
that it should be you want an France
just broader than that
so what people people in this country
will sit there and say well hang on a
second why isn't the French of being
accurately reported to the extent of
which it should be that reflects the
gravitas and the length of the protest I
would say for example I highlighted a
couple of days ago a leave campaign that
had been just shut down on social media
there is a lot of censorship of a view
that is not deemed to be politically
correct and to me it is that which is
causing the situation though will be out
again this weekend it has declined and
there's so much going on in the world
the media can only if you've got the
whole of France coming to a standstill
in the weekend that's a story if you've
got one car burning in Paris about
France I think maybe I clearly haven't
made sure what I'm talking about is if
people have a certain viewpoint that is
not deemed to be along the lines of the
mainstream media's politically correct
bias it gets so I think I think that
historically that's been the case I mean
I think it's today you know yeah so I
think I think that little sensational
work on let's go won an award I think
now what's part of the problem is that
actually I think we're all we've gone
beyond that to a point where now just
we've lost trust in each other but it
definitely what you're saying in the 90s
built up to this point so that when you
remember golden brown was called a hot
mic talking about a bigger TV woman
because it's not bigoted ons bill it's
not bigoted to speak about immigration
so I think we we got to that point under
the Tony Blair government and Gordon
Brown governments but now it's gone past
that to a point where trust is broken
down have a look at this tulip Siddiq
she had to UM she had to come into
Parliament and delay her caesarean
section and she explains the decision
here she says thank you all for the
supportive messages my decision today
delay my baby's birth is not one I take
lightly let me be clear I have no faith
in the pairing system in July the
government stole the votes of a new
mother it's my duty to represent hampson
in Killman and I will do just that
now look she beat me in an election
announcer comes I'm not one to defend
her but she's got a point the trust is
broken do you not think it's not
actually I think the major issues as
well as is trust between politicians and
the people because who when those leave
constituencies you know that are run by
[ __ ] Belles and Anna sue brie and Nikki
Morden who will they trust again to do
that they asked them to leave they voted
them in on the premise that they were
going to deliver ly and they possible I
was talking last night to a former
cabinet minister in the Blair government
and he said why would anybody go into
politics today why would you do it well
it's Paley's but it but it is but if you
mean you're not getting that you're not
getting the best people to go in because
they're all saying I don't want to take
this well I wanted to I mean know who I
mean I was quite a critical missus right
but I sympathize with you I mean you
look at the job and you'd say why is she
still there why didn't you just is that
important she's setting a new tone Greg
with the idea of inviting mr. Corbitt
inviting some months ago she the truth
is she didn't do it when she didn't win
the big majority saying
korban refused to attend the other
leaders of the parties did turn out to
me to a number-10 corbin didn't turn
concerned about the discourse now
heightened when actually when you look
at the discourse and how it's been for
many men
many many years it's been terrible now
but it's been terrible for a while
people like Nigel Faraj have required
security for years on all sides but yes
we are taking a brexit break you're
watching the pledge on Sky News coming
up I'll be saying let men be men
[Music]